et des chiffres en hausse également en
espagne plus de douze mille cas ont été
confirmés lors des dernières 24 heures
sur le sol espagnol madrid est la
capitale européenne la plus touchée au
point que le gouvernement se réunit
aujourd'hui pour évoquer un possible
état d'urgence dans la capitale est cela
intervient après le rejet du bouclage
partielle de madrid par le tribunal
supérieur de justice de la ville et pour
rom alonso coup vilas député de
barcelone la lutte entre le gouvernement
et l'opposition ne fait pas avancer la
situation alarmante que traverse le pays
et coûté il ya un but politique
il ya une grande instabilité vous
commencez à l'espagne grâce à une
instabilité politique depuis 4 ou 5 ans
et maintenant il y a en outre instruit
les gouvernements socialistes et
communistes et l'opposition du
conservateur du parti populaire alors
les conservateurs du parti populaire
on la mairie de madrid et les
gouvernement régional delà de la
communauté de madrid et il sonne et
affronter et contre le gouvernement est
socialiste et l'espagne alors on voit
clairement que c'est un look basique
même politique et avec les tribunal très
politisée et à l'espagne qui est presque
toujours et prennent parti pour les
thèses des conservateurs et les citoyens
nous sommes les demi finales cette année
ma situation